eu já vi
e aí
já chegou eu quero perguntar para vocês
algo extremamente inusitado eu tenho
certeza que ninguém nunca teve a coragem
num pede de perguntar isso para vocês
algo bem íntimo e eu quero que vocês
respondam com sinceridade
é isso mesmo tem aqui é virgem levanta a
mão por favor
e não não é possível aí um pneu mais uns
quatro cinco gatos pingados mais um
pouquinho
e é eu também acreditava que eu não
teria coragem de assumir publicamente no
meu primeiro ted que eu sou virgem mas
eu fico feliz que vocês também tiveram
coragem comigo alguns de vocês o mais
que eu tenho certeza que no final esse
número vai mudar e muito a você deve tá
pensando o quê que esse maluco que fala
sobre futuro né deve tá falando sobre
virgindade não pede que é sobre o futuro
que não é mais como antigamente o que
que isso tem a ver e se eu dissesse para
vocês que a chave do futuro tá na nossa
virgindade
e querem ver vamos começar quando a
gente pensa sobre futuro o que que vem à
nossa mente planos projetos e
expectativas mas também vem ansiedade e
medos
é e qual é o nosso maior medo será que é
da gente não ter futuro será que é da
máquina do substituir afinal a gente
está vendo isso em todos os lugares em
todas as áreas máquina para lá então
eles essencial para cá robótica para lá
e aí será que são medo plausível será
que faz sentido a gente ter esse medo
até que ponto faz a gente alimentar isso
a gente é tão bom assim prever o futuro
eu acredito que não o que esse medo ele
começou na primeira revolução industrial
quando a primeira máquina colocou os pés
no mercado de trabalho aí o pessoal da
indústria todos começaram a ter medo da
máquina substituir eles mas passou a
primeira a segunda a terceira a gente tá
na quarta revolução industrial e a
máquina ainda não substituiu a que bom a
notícia renan então a máquina não vai no
substituir será mesmo que é isso não sei
é mas o que eu sei é que a gente é
realmente muito ruim isso em prever
futuro o outro exemplo é que nasceram
negócios bilionários como uber
estremeceu o mercado de taxistas com uma
netflix que quebrou o mercado das
locadoras e até como uma brasileira
cartãozinho roxo chamado nubank e
facilitou a vida de tantos aqui
presentes mas complicou de bancos tão
grandes fato pessoal é que em algum
lugar do mundo nesse momento o melhor e
muitos lugares do mundo tem nerds como
eu nerds como esse então pensando nos
problemas deles e também é o problema é
de todos vocês e eles estão focando em
resolver esse problema para simplificar
todo o mercado e complicar a vida e o
emprego de muita gente como esse cara
aqui que ele tinha um problema simples
ele tinha ido pro estados unidos aos 16
anos não tinha dinheiro nem sequer para
ligar para o pai que tava na ucrânia e
que esse
e ele sentou no problema ele como um bom
e se ele fosse brasileiro disse vai
demorar demais para acontecer no brasil
né a gente sempre acha que você vai
demorar demais não ele não fez nada
disso ele criou uma solução que todos
vocês usam todos os dias ele criou
whatsapp
é de um problema tão simples algo tão
transformador nasceu isso não tá
acontecendo só ali está acontecendo em
vários outros empregos e vários outros
setores e aí quem tem medo do futuro
e eu tive medo do futuro na realidade eu
tô com medo eu tô nervoso é o meu
primeiro teste é a minha primeira vez eu
tô perdendo uma virgindade com vocês
hoje é verdade será que vai ser rápido
devagar será que vai ser bom será que
vai doer
e eu fiquei com todos esses medos é o
topo esses medos aí eu comecei a me
perguntar caramba eu falo de futuro há
cinco anos será que eu tenho mesmo que
alimentar esse medo será que tu faz
sentido
e eu entendi que eu não tinha que trazer
para vocês nada sobre tecnologia às
vezes é mais fácil para mim chegar aí
assim ó larga em direito larguei
medicina aquilo que a gente dizia que
era a profissão do futuro larga
administração economia marketing que
foco em tecnologia afinal tecnologia a
profissão do futuro será que é isso
mesmo não não é e quando eu fui olhar
para tudo que eu falava eu desconstruir
tudo porque eu entendi eu entendi na
minha história a mensagem para ninguém
ter mais o futuro e vocês vão entender o
que é isso
olá meu nome é renan renault esse
bebezinho fofinho aí eu nasci 1990
e eu era uma criança meio nerd meio
deslocada um chorão eu colecionava todos
esses apelidos e muitos outros que o
tédio me censurou eu não pude falar
aqueles que a gente chamou hoje de
bullying né e aí com todos esses
problemas com todos esses medos e
ansiedades uma aconteceu uma coisa na
minha vida que mudou minha vida
completamente uma coisa muito simples
novamente o simples fato de mudar de
escola quando eu ia mudar de escola eu
fiquei com medo eu chorava meus pais não
conseguiram entender eu tava com medo do
novo das pessoas ali presentes isso me
aterrorizou até que ninguém menos cara
vocês queriam ter um conselho desse cara
ninguém menos que a instruem me deu um
conselho que mudou minha vida
e aí também é ele virou para mim e disse
assim poxa assim como você não conhece
as pessoas que elas também não lhe
conhecem pode ser que não seja tão ruim
pode ser que seja bom ele virou para mim
olhando meus olhos eu tava deitado no
colo dele e ele disse
bom e se você não chorar meu filho
oi e eu chorei eu me acabei de chorar eu
não sei se vocês entenderam mas ainda
tem é o meu pai josé aires tem martins
torres é isso mesmo e ele está aqui
presente vídeo agraciando e ele quando
olhou para mim e falou isso eu não
chorar essa frase e se mudou minha vida
tudo que acontecia na minha vida todo
problema todo novo desafio toda vez que
eu tenho que perder uma virgindade eu me
perguntava esse e os esses foram
crescendos e outro me tornei esse cara
meio feinho agora e aqueles medos aquele
as coisas inseguranças e mais coisas que
os esses a montavam o meu a minha ânsia
por esse aumento e aumenta o mesmo mas
não se sóbrios a gente tem que olhar
para nossa vida e não se perguntar o
caminho mais fácil vamos voltar para um
pouquinho de antigamente dez anos atrás
quando a gente vai pedir um táxi
e a gente podia pedir lá ligar para
operadora e ele tava demorando o que que
a gente fazia a gente perguntava e se eu
ligar e perguntar onde o táxi tá ou eu
podia e se eu pedisse outro táxi mas
alguns aqui alguns do mundo se
perguntaram se eu puder saber onde o
táxi tá em tempo real e se assustaram
bilionários e à medida que essas pessoas
começam a se perguntar isso a gente vai
crescendo os desafios vão aumentando a
pressão aumentando a ansiedade vai
aumentando
oi e a gente tem que entender que a
gente não pode perder a nossa essência
eu posso ter crescido que for mas eu
continuo um grande nerd e um chorão como
vocês quase dirão agora de novo isso é
muito importante pessoal porque eu
entendi e por mais que eu trabalho com
máquinas com inteligência artificial com
robótica o que é mais importante se tá
na gente a máquina ela pode substituir
50 homens e mulheres ordinários mas
nunca um homem e mulher extraordinário e
ordinário é aquela parte da gente que
vai se repetindo e vai fazendo todos os
dias a mesmas coisas vai seguindo o
rebanho vive no automático lembra
daquela música deixa a vida me levar
vida leva eu não deixa a vida te levar
leva a tua vida e seu lado ordinário de
ser o lado extraordinário da gente é
esse lado que a gente vai fazendo sempre
o novo o diferente vai perdendo
virgindade diz a máquina ela vai do
substituir se vocês conseguir
e ver o que vocês fazem porque afinal
pessoal não adianta a gente pode pensar
pensar pensar mas se eu pedisse aqui
para vocês 800 pessoas levantaram a mão
quem são médicos tensão advogados
administradores seria uma olá de gente
né mas isso faria de todos vocês iguais
a pergunta tá errada renan se eu pedisse
para cada um levanta a mão e contar tem
cada um é a história de cada um de vocês
seria diferente a única forma de vocês
serem únicos é vocês serem vocês parem
de olhar para o lado parem de olhar para
o jardim do outro homem para vocês
e vocês são substituídas não a máquina
alguma melhor do que isso não adianta a
gente insiste nisso eu podia sim trazer
todas aquelas palavras da moda blocos
têm inteligência artificial entre várias
outras mas não a palavra do futuro é
você são vocês não querem temer não
querem ser substituído pelas máquinas
sejam vocês não se repitam parem de
seguir a manada e aí quando a gente faz
tudo isso a gente começa a se perguntar
caramba será que eu já vou ser
substituído será que eu já sou robô o
problema da humanidade é que ela tá
cheia de seres humanos mas tá sem
humanidade a gente quase não olha no
olho um do outro a gente esquece tá todo
mundo plugado no celular tem pessoas
extraordinárias aos seus lados histórias
incríveis e uma vez combinadas
se transforma o mundo mas não quem é que
manda na gente a gente o nosso celulares
as notificações e são nerd falando
e vamos viver o agora e aí como bom nerd
eu trouxe para vocês uma plataforma uma
plataforma que vai mostrar que a
resposta tá na mão de vocês não precisa
perguntar fora uma plataforma que odeia
o nome de mapa da singularidade depois
você escaneia em esse criar cold não
façam agora vai ter um teste lembra
daquela revista capricho você fazia para
ver se seu boy magia vai voltar para
você é mais ou menos isso mas é uma
coisa diferente vocês vão fazer um teste
e vou entender se vocês vão ou não serem
substituídos e se vocês já foram e ainda
não sabem quando vocês fizerem isso
vocês vão ver se vocês estão sendo mais
humanos ou mais máquinas o que
infelizmente eu diria que setenta por
cento da população tá vivendo no
automático e a gente tem que voltar para
a nossa essência a gente tem que voltar
a ser humano é isso que máquina alguma
e depois disso o pessoal a plataforma
vai pedir para você chamar pessoas
especiais para vocês seu cônjuge família
alguém se conheceu no pede que teve uma
primeira impressão de vocês para dizer
suas qualidades e defeitos eu listei
algumas das minhas aqui
oi opa
o que eles têm alguma das minhas que ir
lá vocês vão convidar várias pessoas e
elas vão anonimamente falar quem é cada
um de vocês imagine que legal a melhor
forma de vocês não serem substituídos
pelas máquinas é sendo vocês sendo
únicos esse cada um que vocês conhecem
de forma anônima poder meter o pau em
vocês falar quem vocês são de bom e de
ruim para vocês encontrarem a ciência de
vocês isso vai fazer diferença e
lembrem-se que nós somos a média das 5
pessoas que a gente mais convive cada
pessoa que no ted ela pode fazer a
diferença na vida de vocês então para
trazer isso ainda mais à tona vocês vão
poder nessa mesma plataforma listar os
problemas de vocês e aí vocês juntos vão
poder resolver esses problemas cada
pessoa que passa na vida de vocês da
história deixa um pedaço dela que nem
nesse exemplo e eu quero saber pessoal
se no final da vida de vocês quem vocês
vão querer ser aquele que todos os dias
faz a mesma coisa
quem vive no piloto automático e que já
é máquina que o a vida deles é bem mais
curta que é dos outros se você vai
querer fazer teu coração palpitar um
pouco ou se você vai querer perder a
virgindade diz todos os dias na vida de
vocês quanto mais seu coração acelerar
quanto mais medo der uso medo como
empuxo usa isso para te fazer a
diferença assim como eu me arrisquei
aqui reinventa todas as palestras para
encontrar a essência da nossa humanidade
eu convido vocês a fazerem o mesmo esse
o diferencial de cada um de vocês
conseguem você já são
o difícil foi a única coisa incopiável
pelas máquinas
e esse a vida foram exercícios de
reinvenção constante decolagens
experiências um de cada um pode ser um
algum inimitável esse a vida a gente
puder viver todo dia alguma coisa pela
primeira vez se encher de curiosidades
entender que a vida está cheia de
virgindade para gente perder por isso eu
pergunto novamente tem aqui é virgem
levanta a mão por favor agora sim se o
mundo está de portas abertas para a
nossa singularidade tem aqui ainda tem
medo dele muito obrigado
e aí
[Aplausos]